[Music]
okay
the right combination is to say x is
one of those and two of these
um well let's take the equation number
two
if i make a picture that satisfies all
the
x y z points that solve this equation
well first of all the origin is not one
x y z
it being zero zero zero would not solve
it
so what are some of the points that do
so
now let's see maybe if x is one and
caitlin ogden was a lot of things but
she wasn't particularly explosive
in any sense of the word she was the sun
dress of a person
cute airy and offensive
and she was quickly becoming the dalton
twins number one marijuana customer at
covington high
but it's hardly a reason to pop like a
zit she's all over me
spraying all over us i wasn't close with
caitlyn
she was just you know a classmate
someone i sat behind or passed in the
halls every day from kindergarten
to senior year we ran in different
circles
but lots of people liked her guys
especially i was gonna ask her to prom
she was so hot i even narrowed down
hotel room options to two choices
she was so open-minded jed hayes was
particularly crushed
oh my god ted what happened caitlyn
exploded
what like a bomb no like a
balloon what
oh my god your shoes
everyone quickly realized caitlyn ogden
was not a suicide bomber
seeing as the only thing that blew up
was caitlyn ogden
her desk remained unscathed by the ogden
blast
the only damage her clothes took was
cosmetic
this isn't right she was just a kid it
wasn't right
she was just a kid disgusting
and it was very disgusting
after the unprecedented event all of our
third period class got taken to the
police station
which was very exciting we got asked a
lot of important questions like
caitlyn ever say anything suspicious
about wanting to blow up
all the time
i was kidding
then they took all our clothes and let
us shower
will i get these back do you want these
back
[Music]
i only wash my hair then they gave us a
bunch of ugliest [ __ ] sweatsuits and
made us wait
it was like a cronenberg movie
what do you think happened aliens
it wasn't aliens bro i'm just saying she
was there then she wasn't
not fair she was so nice
i was gonna ask her to prom she was very
open-minded
when the hell are they gonna let us out
of here when they know it's not gonna
happen again
then what's gonna happen again
it happened again it happened again a
[Music]
lot
you mind if i join you guys tess don't
look now but there's a boy staring at us
i think he's staring at you oh right you
are and keep me down
tell me something just for me first time
i saw you was right after spiros
introduced me in front of the class
it was a good first impression
[Music]
caitlyn was cute airy hardly a reason to
pop like a zip
what happened caitlyn exploded what like
a bomb
no like a balloon what
will i get these back do you want these
back
in the hell are they gonna let us out of
here when they know it's not gonna
happen again
then what's gonna happen again
it happened again a lot you know you
can't keep a good girl
listen everyone's scared duh duh kids
are literally blowing up
i think they're doing tests on us what's
your name for the record please
you can ask my lawyer i have a moment
for you where i knew i liked you
you liked me i just bought it today
why i was saving up for a college car
but then i thought i might die tomorrow
that should be our school slogan
what's gonna happen to us
[Music]
at least now you can't say things were
so much harder back in my day
you're right you have a way worse
[Music]
you